we're seeing this day by day all of us
in our individual lives
actually there's a woman who went viral
on tick tock yesterday who is claiming
that she was fired from her job for
doing her job
because a woman of a racial minority
was able to claim without any evidence
that she was offended
implying the woman did something wrong
and the young woman lost her job
so i normally don't do this on tick tock
but today i am livid so
i want your opinion to see if this kind
of thing is justified
so i work at a retail store and i've
worked there now for like a year and a
half well i'm moving these racks
and i didn't want to hit anyone so i
kind of look to each side to see
if anyone's on the other side to see if
i can move it well i look this way and i
end up seeing someone so i stop and i
don't move it
well she instantly looks at me and says
can i help you with something
and i'm like oh no i'm sorry i was just
going to move the rack and i want to
make sure i didn't hit anyone
well then she says i want to put a
corporate complaint against you for
racial profiling because apparently
i looked at her the wrong way and was
assuming she didn't have money
i would never just assume someone
doesn't have money by what they look
like that is
stupid well i had to give a whole
statement about the thing
and overall they called me up today and
fired me due to
me looking at someone and being racist
so do you think that's justified or do
you think that's wrongful termination
because i'm pissed i don't know if this
particular story that this woman is
telling is true i have no reason to
disbelieve it
but i think we have all seen
evidence that these sorts of things
happen just the woke woka cola be less
white campaign that linkedin has now
taken off of their platform
thankfully just that alone shows you
that this sort of thing
happens you can be accused of racism for
saying something that's true you can be
accused of racism
for looking at someone
i don't necessarily blame the left
wingers
who are using this political strategy
because
the left is frequently dishonest
they they if they are rejecting a sort
of transcended moral order then they
really have no problem with
being dishonest and lying about these
things and it's very effective
it's a grift it's a total
grift we're seeing actually some
fissions among
some of the most prominent race hustlers
in the country because race hustling
is big business blm has taken in
lots and lots of donations since the
george floyd killing
or the george floyd death i guess we'll
find out in the trial whether he died
of drugs or health problems or whether
he died because he was
he was killed by somebody
but this is big business i read that
there are some numbers it's hard to get
exact
exact numbers here but i have read that
blm has taken in something like 90
million dollars
might be significantly more than that
and some other race hustlers
want in on the action i hope you enjoyed
that clip from the michael knowles show
to check out the full episode
hit the link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you